yo what is up everybody this is your boy
prestige hello and today I have my thank
you so thank you guys this thank you is
just not any thank you though it is in
the form of a new series and this series
will be as you hopefully watch the video
about oh I'll check that up check that
out check that shovel my back wall will
check that pickets on my back board this
series will get out feed the beast if
you didn't know what ftv was before this
then you will own out and that's not
going to work and so yeah I sent out a
video like a week ago I just said ftv so
it's a little ominous oh if you guys
played it before you guys know it is and
so yeah this is basically i guess a
compilation of Martha's description a
compilation of mods and I guess yeah i
think is just mods but it's called feed
the beast and be something soon is like
energy yeah the other whatever but it's
a mop a tub grouping of mod packs that
you basically it's not like you download
at once and you get the launcher and
then you just go ham in it and you'll
see like for one you can see that show
oh I got actually got to show you for
one you saw that that utility piece the
tool on my back at that but don't worry
I'm not cheating of this this this isn't
cheat mode too many items this is recipe
books and like see if I go something
that you guys know uh oak wood slab no
that is no recipe okay that was done
with me a trip our hook it shows me that
I need a stick and iron good and a piece
of wood now you might notice these are
fluctuating this because there's like
four different ways to make everything
and I'm definitely gonna need this
because if you look right here there are
87 cages a different buildable I guess
technically
little of things like that these are all
serums I've no idea what ceilings do so
this series is gonna be about you you
guys and me going through just feed the
beast and just go ham in it and learning
how to do everything and what's doing
yet either alright so now I'm going to
show this actually I really like this I
found a ginormous super tree that you'll
see in a second so I took up a little
bit under it and sorry i just got the
basics out of the way so that is there
so that that's the entrance to my house
and there were these little annoying
like fairy things they look like the
ferry from link i forgot its name from
amazon but they basically I they look
exactly like that in their annoying as
heck they like they like need attack so
yeah there's the here's some stuff I
guess Meyer actually that I remember but
I got ya I pick up a bunch of something
over here I got blueberries I got mallow
berries I got a shard of minium so I
know what some of this stuff does cuz
I'm sticky resin that's big one I know
some of this stuff does because I played
feed be once before they're not too sure
so unsightly let's just show the house I
haven't made a walkway out here and so
that's that that's a ginormous supertree
one day we're gonna hollow that out and
do something with it but not that day is
not today oh it's like there's an
entrance an entrance is just like trees
being all funky of whom them but that's
what I also look at houses front right
there so first things first I want to
show you is a bit it's called a rubber
tree and up there goes my axe and when
you this is like there are two types of
rubber trees there's one like we're d1
and one normal one and this is the
normal one it use all your stuff and
forth like this is the weirding one I
that bad these ones these ones so when
you break it you get rubber wood and
sticky resin or instead of breaking them
if you get a big farm going you can use
a pick sap thingy and juice HAP remember
mama and you can just get the sticky
resin glad destroying the tree and then
the tree can make more
basically because thinking reston can be
made into oil and oil makes a ton of
stuff in this so let's just go materials
and you this is the first thing you
spawn in with let's just get through
alright alright so this is going to be
helping me by Skylar thank you Skylar
are getting sorry wrestling nope can't
cucos okay are uh too much reading so
over berries but Papa Papa berries you
can making some nuggets and ingots okay
I haven't seen one of those they don't
need it okay crafting stuff okay so
planks and sticks is a blank pattern and
a sensitive I don't know what you need
that for but let's make it aha I need
some water that doesn't suck our plants
that are planks utter plans with which
you schmuck boy and then poop and then
Boop and then poop nawa LA and I
completely figure out what the other
thing looks like click no click alright
rights okay so we just bad all right no
craft all right I can craft is just on
my person but whatever 00 materials in
you oh you just gave me the next one
there's another then you can make a part
crafter okay and then a pattern chess a
tool station to forge a punji stick a
barricade oh the grout seal brick seared
bricks smeltery controller yeah so
that's we're making okay so this is v2
than mighty smell things that's how far
that's like a v2 so I don't throw this
boy in there I don't really know what to
do with you since I know party what that
is alright so actually let's make the
other stuff that you talk about so i'm
probably going to need some more sticks
and there then Boop not bad that's it
then well I could just three stencils
now if we attach a monologue so yeah the
first few episodes probably going to be
a little bit of learning as we go and
act
that hopefully it will be better
experience haha well no no I don't go
try and chop okay going mmm arts log and
then you make a pattern chest
toolstation are let's make it to let's
make our salute to 0 station we don't
need a pattern ships for it now to roll
station looks similar to the stencil
thing but sure it's not so park builder
tool station all back Oh what does this
man is ok if you pick ax you make this
stuff pickaxe oh oh so you put a pickaxe
and then you put some in get or
something and powder and you get your
special pickings oh no so oh no no
that'sthat's the repair so you need to
pick X head a tool binding and a handle
how do you meet that battle sign what
the heck's of a dulce are um maybe ok so
you need so for a pic you need pick X
head to go binding in a hand ok so let's
go to E and let's search in pick our pic
x head ok so iron pickaxe head ok we
don't have that yet nope nope nope we're
not doing that yet ok ok give some iron
oh so we make some iron tools a little
bit all right let's look ok so I've no
idea do that so we're back up some
messed up now and let's go into
materials and you next our tools
materials I'm auto parts hey just what
we're talking about her pic x pic x-head
tool rod and to a binding shovel shall
they secure the other I know what shovel
is ok ok a hatchet matic broadsword
longshore rappy air I want abroad so
that's what I want a frappe I what I
wanted Roger in a Friday paddle son
class lethal joke when does that mean he
worked on
alright so these are all the tools they
hang out a lot of tools would oh yeah
what is good thing oh this is showing me
how fast each thing is 00 like the level
of each thing well what cactus cactus my
needs v5 you can make cactus a form of
wood only found it does it ok can make
putting tools you make cactus tools you
can make bone tools of sitting tools Oh
Lou might tools there are tools loose
I'm tools rings I'm tools hmm Corinne
and Corinne it from food in me is from
converting it from you they're really
500 ok good slime crystal slimy mud
slime crystal paper tape step cobalt are
they mine own copper local pushing their
steel bronze diamond in ours is this is
a tool station so if you add a diamond
on to thank you Diamond tinted organ
emerald 10 sets are going to redstone to
it we can do something when you're gonna
catch moss so you can lava to it Oh
gives you the power first smell blocks
as they're harvested sets mobs on PI
over 3 seconds stacks with luck and no
compatibility compatibility not
compatible with silky that's awesome how
do I get that little lava brick melting
a lava crystal that's how you make a
lava crystal that's difficult oh my gosh
this is freaking 20 pages are they okay
so there aren't too many who this is
interesting okay well that was a lot of
information a lot of reading ok so this
back off from the readings let's make
sure you want to keep these boys on our
person too why do I pull during the live
quotes there's a blank pattern and
they're all right so let's make some us
some
irons who was probably need a little
more would make a set of iron to lose
all would it was advanced from the Stone
Age probably get rid of all this aren't
okay so first things first you want our
selves double pics and now we're going
to do let's just put all the things are
there yet so then acts shovel and a
sword art did I get ya ghali gets up art
so I'm going to just dump this stuff or
what I think my recording made it just
stopped no okay we good alright so we're
just going to throw you there you there
you there for you then put you there
like that a little bit this fat and good
good good art so we got a whole of our
tables oh yeah I have had like a little
neighbors off you just chillin me for a
while all right um II asleep last night
sleepy time so yeah I actually when I
was trying to record this um while
trying to record when I was setting this
up like when I was both everything burn
I was going around just kind of relaxing
all cool and I i I'll get a lot of low
frames on this on pita beast and it
turns out this was running on my
integrated processor which is not much
decisioning and that processor
integrated uh where am I talk about into
dog thank you up ok well you get got a
thumb a little bit minerals it's okay I
was on my rug feed the beast was running
on my integrated graphics processor
there's and graphics card where birds
and I was getting like 15 frames so then
I'm like oh I got switched out to my
main big boy in video and all I got the
full frames blew through the roof gotta
like a hundreds
and this is being reported in 60 and it
will be uploaded in 32 to you I didn't I
I think I'm 60 is good for recording and
because yeah just things thanks for
thanks stop good I know no same come
yeah hello i love using gosh for I
should hang I'm really tempted to go
make a tree separate no no no Laura
let's go explore actually look get all
the mind goes around are my house shall
life like there and say let me get the
skills we can shoot me I need a pen
nothing skeleton I really want to finish
mine that Colin copper but you're a
little you're a little hater sure and
our that's all the copper and there was
some other random thing oh there's a
random thing right there EDD four
minutes so what Meryl is this so I
passed something on my way to this house
I was called up iron gravel org and it
was iron ore except in grab so that's
gonna be something we're gonna find and
are are are actually remember this
mineral and this is an annoying annoying
mineral that's found in pocket of like
three kajillion the possibilities the
rank entire lines like I will get in
multiple sacks of this appetite stuff
from a single or in cinema or vein it's
kind of annoying but uh yeah Oh probably
probably end pretty soon si si you ain't
gonna line to blend there Oh getting all
of them are all minus then awareness
please then we're gonna go check out the
oil spill over there you've no word I
can't do anything with this I don't know
why won't you go but we all took at that
so dense not my mom
petal green green hue aniline
philosophers in the normal pork chops
are you so they're over there you see
natural oil spills natural hazard that
trial it mutual nature and all the
source now we will go soon the oil and
be rich like the billions of you buy you
guys hear about the thing where there's
a hotel new body getting the guests free
out gold off adds one good to be back
however those probably calls like sixty
thousand dollar hotels so yeah so this
is oil this is something that makes the
world go round that I can suck so you
see steve steve is a very resilient
person you can brave the cold cold cold
cold frost I said called 15 * of the
tundra you battle the heat of the desk
that any water you can't even swim in
oil oh yeah this um I think you get
pumped so there's things for pumpkins
game in this a part of this map app ffff
Anna I pack and they let you as they say
pump and so the oil like he goes down to
the ground like New York bedrock and you
can apparently pump it out of there
that's what my friend told me if that is
wrong I apologize and if any of you have
played ftv a lot and are like yelling at
me whenever I'm doing anything you ever
seen these be sure you just leave in the
comments suggestions tips of what i
should do because I'm really out of my
element here and I don't really know
what I should do i live in kill sheep
I'm always good at that oh no I guess
I'm not always gonna cheat yeah I gotta
stuff is it good good I'm like I'm gonna
go make it set also something next
episode yeah some episode in the future
we are going to renovate the inside and
the outside then that might be an all
one episode but that that's going to be
the future alright so SAP no point if TT
these are all these are all different
saplings whether they're saying
madness all right let's arm tree oh
there we go treat at that's electric a
treat at treat death as we want so it's
five pieces of wood okay in that order
and you there I'm gonna need a bigger
chest so wood wood wood wood wood haha
i'm gonna make a few of these just
because i think they'll run out yeah 40
great they don't stack that's pleasant
let's throw some coal in there for the
rest of their booboo poop and lets go
click let's go taps itself where hold up
first things first boo boo boo boo boo
no wait wait no no it doesn't make rock
it doesn't make oil it makes rubber haha
I like you guys does it make make sure
we see that's the bad rubber this is the
good Reverend who rubber ok you can ok
minimum stone that's too much or you can
just smelt sticky resin anyway I hold up
hold up smelting yet just felt sticky
resin is anything smelting think our
once the coppers been smelting all smelt
all month since risen a lot more of it
cuz i'll hit up these good was he
basically just take this you look for
the little orange thing don't see any
order sings in the street or sing oh
there we go who funny sound effects and
you get you get a lot more resin to from
doing this then you get from breaking
the tree alright well I was pretty
disappointing but uh yeah we're going to
go back inside and we're going to make a
another part or address as if I'm in the
future world or we will organize don't
worry about that that day is not today
so I'm sure wrote all of you in it or
youth or you okay i'll keep you most of
you for you keep those you out you're
going to nothing Seaver ism you probably
get a mineral show see also charms menu
so basically kill zombies
you're our minimum make that make a
minimum stone which is similar to a
philosopher's stone which i think is
referencing a ton of other things but
that lets you do all the good stuff say
how are you now we have rubber rubber
guys yeah bro Robert way way hmm like a
basic machine okay there's an iron
furnace general a Jenner I think I think
generator is the basic mission of paper
mill nuclear reactor ooh that's a thing
that's that's amazing a machine blog
permission may wishing blog macerator
extractor okay link an extractor gets a
lot more oil out of your sticky person
so we need yeah you see cop right sup I
say this gonna say say your see you guys
a goodness you guys are getting getting
a little taste of what something like
it's gonna be some crazy stuff to see it
guys the series oh gosh still have a
changeable skin from samuel l jackson
egg but this series is going to be 0
hopefully one of those are searching
blur okay sorry guys i had your heads
church cooped up in this room too long
too long we have this series is gonna be
pretty cool on the move around for you
is gonna be a thank you as I said in the
beginning for 500 subscribers I know and
now I have like five 20 but um just a
thank you for the support you've shown
me and whenever you click that like
button I favor button especially that
subscribe button if you're not that
means a lot and I hope everything is
good with y'all because everything's
good to me and I think it's about it if
you get to the end which I'm assuming
negative one percent of you people did
then make sure you hit that like button
if you're not subscribed subscribe
favourite it if you were the one if it
was one of your favorite videos ever
I'll nod and do much in this bed this
video I'm not sure of i favorited myself
I don't know but if you really enjoyed
it then biowing feel free I'm
alright guys that's about it and I'll
see you all later adios